so und hier ist sebastian hämer er tritt
an für ein nicht so dicht besiedeltes
bundesland es ist mecklenburg vorpommern
dafür aber wunderschön habe ich das
richtig gesagt ja das hat richtig gesagt
also ich glaub flächendeckend
vielleicht entdecken das ist glaube ich
doch ziemlich groß aber so sehr dünn
besiedelt also ich glaube wenn du mit
dem flieger drüber fliegt dann siehst du
nur nachts so einzelne kleine bringt
ihnen die da leuchten und du trittst
jetzt für mecklenburg vorpommern beim
bundesvision song contest an was ist das
für ein gefühl erhebend gänsehaut auf
jeden fall also
ich habe die sendung ja immer verfolgt
seit fünf jahren jetzt also seit vier
jahren jetzt ist er das fünfte mal und
ich fand das
schon immer richtig richtig cool und ich
wollte immer für mein land antreten von
meck pomm weil ich ja von daher kommen
ich bin der küsten kind also ich komme
vom gas vielleicht kann das einige leute
muss ich jetzt mal sagen da hab ich
schon mal urlaub gemacht jedem nur zu
empfohlen empfehlen da gibt es ein
wunder kleinbahn taito ahrens so
wunderschön auf das künstlerdorf also
das ist das ist wirklich da kann man die
seele baumeln lassen würde ich mal sagen
definitiv also ich lasse hier schon seit
31 jahren baumeln
deswegen auch dein titel ist schon okay
genau deswegen nur deswegen habe ich ihn
geschrieben und die leute da so so
locker entspannt ist das so nennt man
sagt ja heute entschleunigt gegend also
es wird uns ja nachgesagt dass wir so
kühl sind und was ich was aber also ich
find uns total entspannend net
sowie der wind weht
wie sehen denn die chancen bei dir aus
was rechnest du dir aus ich habe mir
darüber noch gar keine gedanken gemacht
so wirklich also sind natürlich harte
konkurrenten da
auch das gezeichnete ich finde ich auch
sehr gut also den song allein finde ich
sehr gut ich hatte ich natürlich da
unheilig die großen namen aber
wäre es am ende macht keine ahnung ich
will auf jeden fall nicht nur unter
werden was ich war in den charts neunter
und damals bei so einem anderen
wettbewerb der stimme 2003 war ich da
und da war ich auch neunter und ich will
mal irgendwie unter die 9 also ja gut
dann haben wir schon letztlich das
defizit ist es unter oder über die neuen
es ist eine geringere zahl aber
eine geringere zahl operation ok damit
er das schafft votet für ihn ruft an
beim bundesvision song contest ich
glaube ich habe das irgendwann schon mal
gesagt aber auch für ihn gilt das
natürlich wenn er auch seine musik steht
die findet er findet man jetzt schon bei
youtube auch mal scheint ja natürlich
also ich hatte das ja das zweite album
und die vierte single auskopplung von
dem zweiten euro im flugplan zwar ist es
übrigens und schöne videos zu sehen
auch im april also das müsste jetzt hier
unten von mir aus gesehen links
auftauchen diverse videos von ihm und
die mal gucken und dann für ihn voten
und natürlich auch hier auf youtube sums
up favorisieren das video so oft sehen
wie ihr könnt wenn ihr mögt und
natürlich dann beim bundesvision song
contest anrufen ich glaube du bist damit
mir einer meinung richtig richtig
richtig